yesterday during the press briefing of
a white house press secretary jenn saki
there was a clarification about joe
biden's tax plan when joe biden said
nobody earning under thousand
dollars a year we'll see an increase in
taxes
did joe biden mean individuals earning
up to 400k
or did joe biden mean households earning
up to 400k
during yesterday's press briefing gen
saki clarified
that it means households that is
different
than four hundred thousand dollars per
person it's four hundred thousand
dollars
per household and within moments on fox
news
right-wing host charles payne as well as
republican senator chuck grassley
were saying look look we told you
joe biden is coming for middle
income people take a look at this clip
so then what if we go the exact
opposite way we know taxes were promised
and elections have consequences but i
don't think anyone thought
that the president president biden was
talking about
a household making four hundred thousand
i always tell people senator
be careful when you pick up your
torching and pitchforks sooner or later
you might end up in front of your own
house
the middle income people of this country
are smart enough to know that when they
hear a politician
or even the president united states say
that only high
income people the very wealthiest are
going to pay the tax
they know better if you go
there you're going to eventually end up
paying
taxing middle-income people so there are
two relevant parts here
first is is 400 000
as a household income is that middle
income
that's the first question the second
question is
are these the folks we should be
targeting for higher taxes so
when you say 400 000 for a household
that could be two people making 200k
each that could be someone makes 175 and
someone makes 25
could be you know 350 and 50. total 400
000 that puts you in the top two percent
of households in the united states so by
definition you're not in the middle
if you're in the top two percent now you
could say well
you're in the middle like you know you
anything that goes down to the second
percentile
and up to the 98th counts as middle and
then you've got
two percent of people that are poor and
two percent of people that are rich
i don't think most people would imagine
that the meat of the curve
is the middle 98 for example or the
middle
96 percent by definition if you're in
the top two percent you're not in the
middle income now you can go and look at
this for yourself if you go to dqydj.com
you can type in any household income if
you type in 400 000 for example
you will see you're in the 98th
percentile the top to get into the top
two percent this is 2019 data
to get into the top two percent you had
to make as a household
387 000 it's a little higher now
probably because of inflation
it's right around 400 000 a year puts
you in the top two percent
now the second part is actually more
interesting to me
you can like they're they're just wrong
that 400k is middle income you're in the
top two percent
the more interesting part is you can
absolutely make the case that we should
be targeting
not people who as individuals might only
make two hundred thousand
as part of a four hundred thousand
dollar household you should be looking
at people that are making five million a
year
20 million a year 200 million a year the
billionaires that there's
so much more meat on the bone there
that you shouldn't even include 400 000
households right now now that is a valid
argument in the sense that
you're not denying reality you're not
saying 400k is middle income now 400k is
still in the top
two percent but you should be targeting
the top one percent or the top
0.5 percent or the top 0.2 percent
400 000 is a lot of money in any city
but four hundred thousand in manhattan
with three kids
is nowhere near the same as four hundred
thousand dollars as a couple with no
kids in alabama
so you just open this up to more debate
potentially
if you make this about 10 million a year
and up or 20 million a year and up
there's no debate
in any city maybe if you have a thousand
kids right but but in any city with one
two three four kids
that's a ton of money anywhere maybe you
start there
and that is a different discussion and
one that certainly could be had but
there is no way to say
biden's coming for the middle class
by starting tax increases at 400 000
it's it's just look at a bell curve it's
not the case
um and and by the way there's one other
hypocrisy here
charles payne and chuck grassley talking
about
middle-income people making 400 000
but a 15 minimum wage is too much
that's just another level of how
everything is just political posturing
none of this is
none of this is honest or they're really
that dumb
you you decide which it is i think that
it's that they're not honest
we'll have more coverage of this on our
instagram
at david pakman show and find my latest
pastry haul by following me
on instagram david.pacman
today's show is sponsored by an
excellent audiobook
called takeover how a conservative
student club
captured the supreme court this is the
latest audiobook from noah feldman it
just came out
and a feldman actually narrates the
audiobook himself
noah feldman of course is a harvard law
professor and constitutional
scholar you may remember him from his
prominent role in trump's impeachment
number one
and the book takeover looks at how the
federalist society became the most
powerful legal organization in the
country
six of the nine current supreme court
justices
are current or former members of the
federalist society
and takeover dives into what the
organization is what it stands for
its relationship with american politics
the federalist
society is an organization anyone in my
audience
should be aware of and the audiobook has
a ton of excellent insight into it and
the role it plays
i really enjoyed listening to the
audiobook i think anybody
in my audience would as well so grab
takeover by noah feldman the audiobook
is just 4.99
and you can get it at davidpakman.com
takeover or wherever you buy audiobooks